situation de risque menace élevée
permanente vigilance absolue sur ce
point au moins le gouvernement est
d'accord la france n'échappe pas au
danger terroriste d'autant que dans une
vidéo diffusée lundi 11 septembre le
numéro deux d'al qaïda annonce et le
passage est passé totalement inaperçu
le ralliement du gspc algérien au réseau
terroriste et menace de frapper la
france christophe nardini mart ou anne
giudicelli arabophone spécialiste des
mouvements islamistes
c'est elle qui en détaillent à décrypter
la vidéo du numéro deux d'al qaïda 1h16
de discours au cours duquel il fait une
annonce mal expliqué que sa mamelle la
dell a chargé d'émotion de bonne
nouvelle l'annoncé donc là l'intégration
du groupe gspc dans l'organisation al
qaïda le gspc
le groupe salafiste pour la prédication
et le combat une organisation terroriste
d'origine algérienne dont le chef avait
à plusieurs reprises depuis 2003 demandé
à rejoindre les rangs d'al qaïda
aujourd'hui c'est donc chose faite
l'alliance est officiellement scellé non
sans intérêt pourquoi est-ce que le
caïdat s'intéresse gspc
ce n'est pas parce que le gspc est un
groupe fort et dangereux aujourd'hui
mais c'est parce qu'il a des choses dont
a besoin qaïda et c'est quoi ce sont
effectivement des militants des réseaux
des cellules dispatchés en europe
disséminés partout sur le territoire
européen
les réseaux du gspc sont nombreux comme
en atteste différentes arrestations
répartis un peu partout dans le monde
en france il ya quelques mois le groupe
bourada et démantelé il serait lié au
gspc en l'an 2000 ahmed ressam inspiré
par le gspc veut faire sauter l'aéroport
de los angeles le saut encore du gspc
pour la cellule de francfort elle avait
planifié un attentat à strasbourg en
2002 dans sa vidéo al zawahiri menace
également les croisés français après la
sphère du voile c'est la deuxième fois
que la france est directement visé c'est
le tamis qui est intéressant
c'est au moment où les troupes
françaises arrivent au liban fortement
armés avec une logistique solide et qui
inquiète aujourd'hui les islamistes
arrivés au mit enfin que les croisés
dont parle d'envoyer ses les français au
liban bien entendu le gspc compterait
entre 300 et 500 combattants
opérationnel la plupart cachés dans les
montagnes de kabylie